dareka is an Ohio Dave I'm going back
and forth about paying out my car I have
$8,000 left my coworker told me not to
pay it off because I have a low APR 4
point 8 4% have the cash to pay it off
and I'm confused dareka your co-workers
broke listening to broke people for
financial advice is like taking dieting
advice from fat people that's stupid
pay your car off and never borrow again
on a car the rest of your life
that's what millionaires say not your
broke co-worker who thinks they can run
a calculator you've got to get out of
the land the car payments if you want to
win with money you cannot win with a car
payment it does not work it is the
mantra of the middle-class you're always
gonna have a car payment translation you
are stuck and then you complain about
crap like stagnant wages because you
won't get off your stagnant butt and
change your life not you too Rico but
the rest of you so mr. Rico pay off your
car today and take no more financial
advice from broke people it would be
like taking advice from me on how to
grow hair that would be stupid I don't
have any hair in case you didn't know on
my head anyway